mutis evolution inspiration war dass
wien von 1900 bis 1918
es war der beginn der modernen alles als
kompliziert war wurde aufgebrochen in
eine
durchaus üppige einfachheit
[Musik]
wir haben immer weitergemacht für frauen
in meist mail dominierten umgebungen
[Musik]
es war ja ein moment für frauen gemacht
frauen damals haben die frauen wahlrecht
bekommen
sie haben das recht zum studieren
bekommen das erste mal durften sie eine
professionalität erlernen diese bomben
in gold mit helen mirren sagt ja genau
aus was diese frauen in dieser zeit
bewegt habe
wir sind auch heute wieder in einen
moment für frauen
was ich an dieser periode schätze ist
die ganze sexualität der ganze luxus das
ganze gefühl für stoff brokate santa
rosa
[Musik]
praktikabilität heute nennen wir das
funktionalität und das ist zusätzlich
das was ich auch in jedem zweiten stock
wie ich suche diese funktionalität für
mich in kleidern und wenn sie
funktionellen sind das ist nochmal eine
meile nachdem die idee des kleides des
mannes oder hose formuliert ist aber das
macht leider wirklich moderne nach 14
jahren wissen wir wie das geht aber es
ist natürlich immer wieder diese neue
idee ist es die musik das alles klappt
dass der raum richtig ist für den moment
der inspiration und es braucht dann die
sechs monate danach oder auch die jahre
danach gesagt wie wichtig die schrauber
und so müssen wir einfach mit jeder
schau auch immer wieder überraschen
[Musik]
wir haben unser bild gezeigt oder wir
arbeiten sechs monate an diesem bild und
es ist nie fertig bis zu dem moment und
wenn die schau vor es ist das bild
fertig was zerfällt meter das ist modern
[Applaus]
nicht um mich es geht um meine kleider
[Musik]